when it comes to popcorn movies phrase
dumb fun might get used by fans and a
lot of people found Suicide Squad to be
just that some fun but once they're just
a bit too much dumb with a collection of
a-list actors as ridiculous comic bad
guys you think it'd be hard to get it
wrong and while the end result has some
great moments the final cut that made it
to the silver screen was reportedly
wrecked by the studio making cuts while
you may have seen the extended edition
at home here are some dumb things in the
theatrical version of Suicide Squad
that everyone just ignored the magic
machine in Contra sexists so the Suicide
Squad can go up against the sexy villain
with generic plan please don't touch me
please don't touch me her big evil idea
filled a mysterious machine to end
mankind that's pretty much it the device
apparently powered by Enchantress's
sweet dance moves and make-out sessions
has never actually explained she just
says she's going to create a giant
garbage tornado to get back at humanity
then it opens up a hole in the sky
enchantress can transform any human into
a member of her jelly army and her
brother has crazy fire whips forearms
that can slice through anything if you
can't take over the world with just that
doing it wrong Lady Justice League who
by the time Suicide Squad rolled around
the flash and Wonder Woman were already
introduced a movie on to have them
disappear during one of the biggest
metahuman crises the world's ever seen
doesn't quite add up it would have been
simpler to set the film free Man of
Steel's and to pretend that these heroes
didn't exist for the big fight Suicide
Squad we could except a fat man called
in sick after learning his lesson about
not fighting super-powered villains but
no Wonder Woman she's all about this
kind of stuff the helicopter crash
suspension to disbelief is pretty
critical when viewing any superhero film
but that doesn't mean you have to toss
out everything you know about physics
and biology in the name of action-packed
evil shenanigans the illusion on it is
when the Suicide Squad helicopter is
shot down as they're entering the city
and does about a dozen flips on the
ground you expect a broken fingernail
with very least the super tough Killer
Croc might come out okay
but somehow everyone hops out of the
downed copter like the fresh out of the
shower all right we know the bad guys
mostly because Harley Quinn announces it
frequently for bad guys it's what we do
and we know they're tough but there's no
way that someone didn't at least banging
me in that crash we'll say it again
we're calling shenanigans I swear to god
I'll pistol whip the next guy that says
shenanigans hey Farva what's the name of
that restaurant you like with all the
goofy on the walls and the mozzarella
sticks
you mean shenanigans no the only bomb in
the universe the first attempt to
blowing up Incubus failed because
enchantress cut out on the team moments
before the bad guy destroying bomb went
off with no way to reset the countdown
instead of setting the bomb for five
minutes or something they based an
entire plan around an unreliable magical
weirdo will say the whole thing was a
bad idea even stranger they only have
one of these bombs and somehow can't
make another so they have to retrieve it
from a flooded subway system at the very
least this makes killer croc swimming
powers actually relevant but it's never
explained why this one bomb is the only
bomb for wiping out the building from
above isn't an option why don't they
just use a drone or something why must
the squad do everything the hard way for
bad guys it's what we do oh okay then
terrible admissions policies Amanda
Waller's entire reason for assembling
the suicide squad was so she could have
her own group of super people she could
control but the team leaves a lot to be
desired while it's kind of accurate to
the comics the film doesn't really make
the reasons for their roster clear
villains like Killer Croc Diablo and
Deadshot makes sense to have around
because their skills can be pretty handy
but what about Harley Quinn and calves
at boomerang Harley Quinn has been shown
to be a clever tactician in the comics
but all of that's replaced with tight
shorts in the film last time we checked
hot pan
born a superpower Captain Boomerang is a
sociopathic bank robber who can throw
boomerangs which are the least effective
weapon of all time
while we're on the subject of the
Captain Boomerang returns after the team
as his near break up towards the middle
of the film the gang decides to get back
together and go face off against
enchantress it's fairly well established
like everyone decides to stick around
for the big fight but then boomerang
just randomly jumps in with them as they
do the heroic walk off into battle
unlike most of the other team members
boomerang never really showed any
interest in being a team player
so why does he come back is it because
he's all into boomerangs and they always
come back
no it's coming back miss why back
throwing stick stunner you always
boomerangs on us and where does he keep
getting those beers maybe that's his
real superpower
captain wrong yank no it's pretty big
and good thanks for watching click the
looper icon to subscribe to our youtube
channel let's check out all the cool
stuff we know you'll look to
[Music]